-I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"my bad luck" stories
from you guys.
This first one
from @sanemomofmany.
She says, "I thought I won
the Michigan lottery
after I hit all five numbers
and the Powerball,
then realized I was looking at
a ticket from the week before."
[ Audience awws ]
Just reading your ticket.
"Oh, my gosh!
I got my numbers that I choose.
From the week before."
Yeah, that's your ticket.
This one is from @angelfan.
She says, "When I was young,
I went through a haunted house,
fell down, and twisted my ankle.
I started yelling for help,
but everyone thought I was
an actor and stepped over me."
"It's pretty realistic!
That's pretty realistic!
She looks like she's in pain!
"She's, like, really crying.
Real tears."
-Oh, man. She looks like
she's really in pain, man.
That looks like real blood!"
This one is from @bearknowy.
-Bearknowy?
-He says, "Out of habit
from texting my wife,
I ended a text to my boss
with 'I love you.'
He texted back,
'I love you, too.'"
-Aww. Hey.
-That's kind of cute.
-Bearknowy.
-This one's from @Sonyaday11.
She says,
"My car was hit by a bathtub
that fell out of a truck.
They don't teach you
to avoid falling bathtubs
in drivers ed."
It's like, "A bathtub?"
Um...
this one's from @slurpeegirl.
-Uh-oh.
-She says,
"I was making mashed potatoes
using an electric mixer.
Little did I realize, I was
scraping all of the Teflon
off the pan I was mashing in.
I told my boyfriend the chewy
black bits were pepper."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Oh, God.
"Why am I so sick?'
-"It doesn't taste that spicy."
Oh, yeah. You're eating Teflon.
This one's from @Juderee.
She says, "I was walking
on a boardwalk at the beach
and got slapped in the face
with a huge slice of ham.
A seagull dropped it."
-Sure. Sure.
Come on, dude.
-Come on.
-That's called a ham slap.
-That's worse than -- That's
worse than a bird pooping.
Yeah, exactly. It's much worse.
-Maybe it was poop.
[ Laughter ]
Giant ham seagull.
[ Slap! ]
That's what it sounds like.
[ Laughter ]
-Last one is from @colbybarrend.
He says,
"I left my ex a drunk voicemail
to come over one night,
but she never showed up.
Turns out I sent the message
to my mom. She did show up."
There you go.
There you have it.
Those are "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.